[Music]
Sandra's back Johnny's back Estelle's
back everybody is back yeah almost
everybody and whoever didn't do it you
know we'll bring them back in the if we
get a continuation after returning for
one season the roseanne reboot has been
canceled by ABC she's finally coming out
of her shell quiet everybody
this after series lead Roseanne Barr
shared an offensive tweet comparing
Valerie Jarrett a former adviser to
President Barack Obama to an ape the
network's president announced that ABC
was pulling the show less than 24 hours
after the tweets writing Roseanne's
Twitter statement is abhorrent repugnant
and inconsistent with our values and we
have decided to cancel her show
Roseanne's cast and crew also spoke out
on Tuesday producer Wanda Sykes said she
quit the series ahead of its
cancellation actress Inlet canning
shared she was hurt and embarrassed by
Roseanne's
comments and Sara Gilbert who acted on
and produced the revival wrote in part I
am disappointed in her actions to say
the least
no no it's terribly sad before the
cancellation news bar apologized to both
Valerie and all Americans for her racist
remarks quote I am truly sorry for
making a bad joke about her politics and
her looks forgive me my joke was in bad
taste
[Music]